Point guard for the best handle you ever saw God. Sham god damn god damn
Guy I've never seen anybody with hands like this his impact on today
I think a lot of these kids owe him a couple of dinners
a
God damn God's hype and oh is in the lead hand it's one of the best handles has ever touched a basketball
today's NBA is the Golden Age of the point guard and in every Arsenal is a weapon that most elite ball handlers utilize a
crossover moon created by God Shambo
Different a lot of times you see a crossover with side to side the ball handler always had control to the ball
But with the sham guide is almost like you exposing the ball more than usual
It's almost like breaking case of emergency crossover
That movie is like very very dangerous to me because you use it in the right
Situation it could be one of those like game-changing moves where you just hit somebody with a sham god
And then the crowd will go crazy
The kids call sham God
Known simply as the sham God the crossover dribble is modern art in motion used on countless hardwoods all over the world I
Usually use it when I know the person can't guard me
Because this is easy, but you know he's gonna reach for he's gonna reach for the throw out, and then when you snatch it
It's just gonna look crazy
I've definitely caught a few people on a sham God or two I remember one in Seattle
I've just got a burner which Jamal Crawford. I hit the big with one that I finish with my left hand
I like the craze behind the guy in God, but I like the I like the actual combination of mood
That's could possibly lead to a sham guy, so if you hit somebody with a combination
Then you hit him with a sham God move. I feel like I get more excitement out of that
Brooklyn born Harlem rage God
Sham guard grew up on the playgrounds of New York City in the 1980s at an early age
his future handles were inspired by a legend I
Was in elementary school and tiny Archibald was my gym teacher
and he always told me one thing is like long as you learn how to dribble you always be worth it to a team I
Used to use one pound ankle weights and put it on my wrist and then
After that everything else is just like creativity and just reaction when I first seen him play in a park not even organized
I knew this kids especially handled because it's always so long and when he crosses
It's almost a roll so for you to try to steal it from him
When he's crossing over and his groove or whatever the case may be
You're gonna hurt your fingers because your fingers are gonna be on the ground a lot of people can dribble the ball
But very few can control the ball. He would put the ball out in front of you, and he had this
remarkable crossover it was like
Mind-boggling, you know quick it was
My coach bill hey bruh the icing what I wanted to be in four years
And that's all I wanted to be McDonald's
All-americans it passes that he could make off to pick a little whip in point we did a lot of picking room
You know and him and Ron Artest
Shamgar flirt at LaSalle Academy
Earning an invitation to the McDonald's all-american game in 1995 the roster included seven future NBA awesome
Messiah with him Vince Carter and Paul Pierce and Shareef abdur-rahim with all these guys and
Everybody was talking about the scam got moved
Following the McDonald's all-american game
sham God met another future NBA star Lower Merion High School prospect, Kobe Bryant the
chance encounter led to an important realization I
Was like who is this kid like he's a nut he's just shooting the ball all the time
So everybody that was at the camp. It was like man
This guy think he's Michael Jordan
His father was like do you work with him while he's dribbling at one thing
I enhanced with him is just throwing to dribble lower star higher come low
That was the first time I meet teaching somebody something and I guess that's the kind of the path I've been on like my whole
life
Shamgar went on to play at Providence where in
1997 he led the friars to the Elite Eight
And the Flyers
Guidance in their regional final matchup against Arizona, sham guards famous move was seen nationwide
It was a play where I was on the right wing act like I was going baseline
Not to to boil out and I ran like five steps and pulled it back with my left hand
The n-c-double-a tournament for me is like
Sweet-and-sour story because it was the worst thing and the best thing that ever happened to me
Because up until that point. I haven't thought about the NBA
Entered the draft, then I got drafted about the Wizards
Looking back. I probably did it a little bit differently it stayed one more year
He would have definitely been a first-round choice, and maybe a lot of reap. Ick you know unfortunately he did?
Well, I came in Biddy Ishak that king of Oz well. Yeah, oh, he's great sinner then the NBA was more of a system
but now you look at
2010 a team they want the point guard to be to scorer the leader I
Was caught in between the times I always teased my moms like man. You know you got me 20 years too early
NC double-a was like my coming-out party, and I don't really feel I capitalized the most from it
and I think one more year would have been suffice and
Story, probably a little bit different now
Shamgar played just one NBA season so he took his career and made his patented handles global
And you
And when I went to China my first year I got MVP, and then my second year
I got MVP with Yao Ming and I was voted the most popular player over there
After a nearly decade-long career overseas Shamgar returned to Providence in 2012 this time as a coach
four years later
he was hired by the Dallas Mavericks as an assistant where every game he witnesses the impact he's had on today's league I
Just think it opens up the game because there's so many combinations
you could do off the move the move itself is so wicked his wick is it's
Identifiable you know it's his so you see ask the goddamn guy
And I've seen people and other players over the years trying to imitate it, but nobody's making look like either
I taught myself
It's next to
Oh
Yeah, kick it up to the esophagus accelerate it really talks. It comes up with a fabulous tilting
It's a different way of
Crossover he knows his own thing you know that's why everybody knows what it is because it was so different
It wasn't like to be kind of back or between the legs was just a right to left or left to right. It was just
Sort of a flashy
Different play the appeal behind it in the craze behind the gosh in God is awesome, man
That movies has definitely been tailored you know over the years, and you see different guys using it for four different finishes
Cystic Ryze is really dope because not even just artist is a former basketball player
When you get a defensive person
Momentum going to my left. Let's say yeah, right all the way, and you know you're not about to go that way
It's like this way you bout to be a smoothie
It's incredibly now looking back on it because
We come from an area
Samba through them our area is filled with so much hate
We come from that generation in that neighborhood to where they not necessarily
appreciate with Sherman's born
Gaza moved that way, I'll live him that move will be around forever. You know everybody comes up
Trying to do that move that particular style is doing something. Yeah, I
Just think now I'm getting the notoriety that I
Didn't get that much when I was younger for putting in all the workers, and I just feel this is the basketball gods repaying me
Understand understand, yeah
The back the core game is no more your whining on the just coming make the phone pick it out longer than a night
And if you did though who's right, I guess I'm gonna
Yeah